im jahr 1968 war ich im grenzschutz bei
der grenzschutz kompanie porträt und
felgen 24 22 als commandante erster zug
eingeteilt und hab natürlich die
entwicklungen in der tschechoslowakei
mit einigem interesse verfolgt vor allem
dieses manöver schon mal war diese
diversen bewegungen war dann aber trotz
überrascht dem morgen auch rechten am 21
august über die invasion in der
tschechoslowakei berichtet wurde
er habe sofort meine familie informiert
dass mit meinem mobilisierung gerechnet
werden müsste und bin dann sofort ins
büro weil bei einer mobilisierung meine
beruflichen agent nie war damals so
kredit referent zu übergeben gewesen
werden und habe sofort meinen
kompaniekommandanten angerufen weil
kompaniekommandant im zivilberuf leiter
der abteilung der bayerischen
landesregierung hat man erklärt er wisse
noch nichts über unsere verwendung er
hätte von hörsching von commander noch
keine informationen bekommen
ich hab dann noch einer weiteren stunde
direkt beim kommando grenztruppen in
hörsching angerufen ob dieselbe
information bekommen ist seien nicht
geplant den grenzschutz aufzubieten
das heißt für mich ist an der dienst
völlig normal weitergelaufen
ein freund von mir nochmaliger oberste
miliz kollmer ist in zivil nach bad
leonfelden gefrorene war damals als
airpark gruppen content meinen zug und
verstellt und hat dort am sammelort dem
posten kommando bereits einige grenzen
gehen ohne form vorgefunden in thunder
bay posten kommando wären unsere user
waren unsere waffen und gerät
eingelagert für die wurde enttäuschung
natürlich groß
völliges unverständnis dass der
grenzschutz genau in dieser situation
für die er eigentlich auch mit
aufgestellt wurden ist nicht gebraucht
wurde
es hat er nur dazu geführt dass der
grenzschutz sehr an sympathie verloren
hat und zwar schlicht und einfach
deswegen weil man über die jahre er
versucht habe über kratzen überlegungen
zu allerheiligen über grenze tabelle und
sonstige veranstaltungen die kontakte
zur zivilbevölkerung zu festigen und
einfach ein positives klima zu schaffen
das ja für territoriale einheit ganz
wichtige voraussetzung ist